the leading poll this time was how to
start a successful online business I
think it just starts with figuring out
what are you selling and when you start
with what you're selling you go to the
next level of how can you start selling
something to make money faster a lot of
people when they're starting they're
selling something that takes way too
long to get going I think people take
too long to start making money and when
you're not making money it's hard to
keep going on your dream when nothing is
coming in and so what's the fastest path
to start making more money so finding a
faster way to get started with the thing
that you're selling so that can make
money more quickly and that's where
usually it's some kind of service I'm a
big fan of starting with a service over
a product because products take time to
be able to make and I want you making
money faster so what can you do at the
beginning to Yes Trade your time for
money because you're trading if you're
at a job or doing something else you're
trading your time for money there I'd
rather trade my time for money doing
something I love and helping people
which then also allows you to make
better products and services like built
to serve the book how do you write a
good book build to serve I wrote pretty
quickly I wrote a third of the book on a
16-hour drive to and from New York with
a broken neck while Nina was driving
because I had to get to New York and I
broke my neck and I couldn't fly they
wouldn't let me on a plane because of
the pressure would impact my neck so we
had to drive there it's like eight eight
nine hours from Toronto and Nina drove
and I wrote third of the book in the car
sitting next to her the section in the
book where I say this is kind of weird
to write because Nina's right now I was
talking about Nina and she was right
next to me like this is a weird part to
write because she's right next to me as
I'm typing this out
I could write it that quickly because of
all the work that I had done to help
people
so a book a great non-fiction book where
you're given advice is basically
coaching at scale
without any feedback
same thing speaking on stage is coaching
at scale without a lot of feedback when
you're coaching somebody and you tell
them something give them some advice
they give you some kind of rebuttal they
you feel like where they're struggling
you can get a lot more personal but when
it's in a book they're still thinking
the same thing but they they're not
telling you when you're creating the
core same thing
uh when you're speaking same thing and
so before going to a book or course or
speech I'm a much bigger fan of doing
the work to help people so that you know
what their resistances are you know what
the feedback is going to be that then
when you move to a a bigger audience
um you can already address most of those
issues because you've done it so much
before in the one-on-ones so I think it
I think it doing a service first pays
you immediately which is awesome and
also helps you make better products and
services because you've got
um more experience in helping people so
that was the topic of the day uh now we
usually we throw it over q a whatever
you got for me there's a little uh
reactions thing at the bottom that you
can use if you click on the reactions
face you can then raise your hand and
we'll bring people up you just will
unmute you and ask you a question and
try to help as much as possible Tanya
she was on she was on front stage at the
built to serve challenge that was fun
I want to to to to to I don't know if
the word is correct I want to launch a
course because I already have the
experience I know the I mean I know what
to what would be useful for for people
in this case in this case international
students I know how to help them to you
know through the whole process of from
starting from their countries to get
here to Canada I know all that like I
know that I have the experience I've
been doing it for so many years 14 years
so I know that but I don't know how to
make it attractive like
the structure and how to launch it
that's the part that it's kind of like
uh
you know uh detaining me from from
finally put this uh everything in place
and being able to launch and to and to
and put the course together yeah so
I mean it's you could do it through
videos you could do it through PDFs you
could do it through PowerPoints you can
give people part of it also like the
forms and how to fill out the forms
right if you're trying to get into
Canada what are the forms that people
need to fill out and give them the
templates so that they can do it right
and I think if you can position it as
the education and the experience that
you've like you know how to get it done
so that you have the wisdom
plus the templates here's how you
because those government forms are
terrible like none of them make any
sense right but it wouldn't be directed
into the immigration part because that's
very it's very too much liability and it
changes a lot so it is hard to to to
coach a distance about that I wouldn't
go that way I wouldn't I would be more
interested or I think that it would be
more useful to create what you were
saying today in the morning something
that it's not limited by time like
something that is going to be good now
and and maybe five years later because
laws change too much immigration law
changes too much so it wouldn't be that
good idea to focus in the immigration
part I would create them I think is
create a chapter about immigration like
immigration 101 kind of like give them
an initial insight about it but make it
more about education and the process of
uh of of you know deciding and studying
and finally going through the process of
selecting is cool what's best what type
of education they are looking for like
guide them through from the beginning to
the end till they you know find the
school and they get to Canada but more
from the education plan this time or
point of view so I mean the reality with
any courses it will need to have some
updating because even in yeah
even in the the only thing that wouldn't
be updated is to be talking you know
mindset or belief or any of the personal
development stuff but if you're helping
pick between schools like which school
am I going to go to even if we're
ignoring immigration which school do you
pick
well things might change about the
school or a school might go out of
business or a school might merge with
another school or you know that so you
you have to think about you'll be
updating the course probably once a year
as a commitment yeah that would be okay
it's terrible but so even in that then
like if you can package the wisdom to
know because you've done it and you have
the experience with the templates so
even if the templates are not going to
be government related
you still have to apply to the school
you still have to fill out different you
know so like the more that you can have
done for you stuff in there as well that
they can copy and paste and walk through
it's just an extra layer on top of just
the wisdom and then if we talk if you
Circle back to what we talked about on
the build to serve challenge with the
concept of love and and helping
um educate Latin American women
uh mothers Latin American Mothers was it
uh yeah yeah that would be my ideal
group like mothers with children and uh
that are in a situation that they would
need some skill to move forward like
some additional skills to move forward
and that would be language English
so if part of that is hey by buying your
package I also can support a class oh
that's good that's great it's not the
whole thing but it's it's a nice add-on
that hey if I buy your course if I spend
however much money to buy your course it
also helps me buy a class to help 30
mothers in Latin America learn some
English to improve their skills this
week right that's how you stand out as
your your business and then and then so
that's the like that's the that's the
course you have your course receive your
videos or PDFs or PowerPoints
then you have your templates that they
can fill out that you guide them through
the process of how to fill it out or
create your own templates for you know
we have a bill to serve does the build
serve book but there's also the
worksheets that go with the book I saw
yeah so that's the template like I'm
creating a template for people because
there's the book but then hey here are
these sheets that you can help fill out
and we'll guide you through how to do it
so what are the templates that people
can have in addition to the wisdom and
then if they feel like they're
connecting to something bigger so it's
not just about them but they're also
helping mothers in Latin America learn
English to get you know more freedom for
themselves
that's the that's the cherry on top
um that's nice thank you so that's what
I'm looking for the course and then
promoting it it's content and also who
can help you promote it you know who who
is talking to these students before they
did make this decision that they might
help make introductions for you maybe
even take a referral fee for the making
those introductions
okay thank you very much thank you good
luck
the first question that came in on the
poll was how can we focus on one thing
with too much information
so at the beginning of anything
it always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which audiences and just
testing tests and test and testing until
I kind of get a sense of okay this is
where the gates are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
now it's Evan Evan's holding up to two
percent I got mine I got mine too make
the two percent happen anyway so I hope
that makes sense right it's taking that
big idea that seems overwhelming that
seems impossible and then finding one
step that you can do today because as
long as you have it as some big dream in
your head that is impossible then you
never take any action and then you know
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing yet because it still
seems too impossible and I see it all
the time with entrepreneurs who are
getting started people ask you how do I
get started on YouTube how do I get
started as an author how do I get
started as a speaker and and you think
you've got to have this perfect plan and
the perfect gear and all of this perfect
stuff and then it's a year later and you
still haven't done the thing immediate
action momentum I see Zayn's big smiling
um Dan joined me on my uh three days a
week now I stream League of Legends and
answer business questions and Zen joined
in and they said yeah I'm gonna start
making YouTube videos uh and I think it
was original timeline was like next
month or in two months or something it's
like dude Zen come on tonight make a
video let's go get get your video up uh
and then he did and he got his first
video up and then the second video and
then another video like he's got his
phone out he's gonna make another video
right now
like that's the process and and it's not
gonna be perfect being off your phone
and it's and it's not gonna be the the
lighting that you want or the gear that
you want or the background that you want
and your thoughts may not come out as
clearly as you want that's the beginning
like the beginning is supposed to be
messy so don't stress out about having
all the information at the beginning
just go just create like in that
momentum uh you will start getting some
results
um and additional momentum to keep on
building right and
I think a lot of you know my story about
losing that 40 million deal when I was
22 years old of just trying to be too
perfect and have it all planned out and
you know
going to Market and then seeing Oh My
Perfect plan was not what people wanted
anyway right like your perfect version
of a YouTube video is not going to be
perfect anyway once you start creating
it's going to change it's going to take
a million different turns
um so the best way to do it is to do it
so to take action against that big idea
so it doesn't just stay
uh doesn't just State an idea for you
forever okay next question Nicolette
said what is your advice on where to
start with content creation if you
haven't started at all
so the easiest place to start is
actually Instagram stories like easy is
easiest easiest place to start is
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's it's meant
to be informal it's meant to be
non-edited it's meant to be kind of
behind the scenes and so if you're
trying to develop that practice of being
a speaker of creating content I
recommend starting like Ground Zero you
start with Instagram stories and try to
find three to ten moments during the day
that you can share you know you where's
my book built the serve right you guys
you guys you have this book if you're in
this group right you've you've got it
hopefully you've read it it's not just
some fancy ornament sitting there on
your desk Zane's got two copies Victor's
got his copy
I love it Evans I know it's got an
entire shell full of uh of books
somewhere there at the top
um so you know it's it's about starting
to share the way that you think to serve
other people you you're weird you're
different you're I like to say you're a
weird duck you think differently your
job is to teach me to think like you
think so some of the things that may
seem super obvious to you for other
people is not so obvious right if I look
at even your your rooms for those of you
who I can see you know your your rooms
like why does Zan have Captain America
shield on his wall you know why does
Evan have Napoleon Hill on his wall and
Andrew Carnegie Doug's Doug's trying to
hold up built to serve but it's being
blocked out by then by the Florida coast
uh you know why does Jeff have Steve
Jobs up on his wall right Michael's
showing believe up on his wall right
like why why do you have these in your
rooms in your offices it means something
to you and that may be like maybe maybe
Zan's been a Captain America fan since
he was eight years old I don't know like
maybe that's just so natural normal for
him but for other people it's kind of
weird to have a Captain America shield
on your door right like most people
don't have that so explain why it's
there right explain why you picked up
this book most people wouldn't know that
that's Napoleon Hill up on Evan's wall
right so explain why he's there explain
what that message means and finding
these micro moments throughout the day
from your your routines your habits what
you're eating for lunch what happened
when a client emailed you like the way
you respond to things is different and
so that's your job it's not about how
fancy the the video footage is it's your
job to teach me to think the way that
you think and sometimes this is hard to
step about it because for you it's so
natural and normal because you've been
doing it for a long time but for
somebody else who's watching you from
the outside it's it's weird and
different and that's the whole point and
so Instagram stories I think is the
easiest way to start just to get you
into that practice of creating content
again you know three to ten different
stories a day it takes 15 seconds Max so
you know at the minimum I'm asking for
45 seconds a day right this is not a
groundbreaking amount of time to create
content right 45 seconds three 15 second
stories a day
when you're ready to jump in and make it
much bigger
I would look at YouTube as my primary
home and then I would split up the
content to go to the different platforms
so when you can get to making one
YouTube video per week I want a 10
minute YouTube video every week and it
could just be taking me deeper right Zan
has a 10 minute story about the Captain
America shield Evan has a 10-minute
story about what he's learned from
Napoleon Hill Jeff has a 10 minute story
about what that Bullseye thing is behind
him right you know Michael has a
10-minute story about what believe means
to him right it's it's just taking me
deeper into it but the the Instagram
content stories is the first way to just
start practicing getting it
out of your head out of your mouth and
into the internet right into the world
um once you can get to 10 minute video a
week that's where I want you to be on
YouTube
because those that content will live
forever and then you split up the
content to go to all the different
social media platforms so until you're
ready to do that Instagram stories once
you're ready to do that then you can
still do the Instagram stories right
it's just add-on it's additive again the
Instagram stories are 45 seconds a day
everybody here has 45 seconds today to
record three Instagram stories to tell
me about something that's happening in
your life and and it's not this was
really hard for me at the beginning of
making content was it's not about
uh
telling me what you ate for lunch and
just kind of vlogging
it's trying to find a message in
everything so if you're showing me your
lunch tell me why you picked that thing
like why are you picking asparagus for
lunch or why are you having that
Donut for lunch like why why are you
picking that thing like explain to me
the thought process behind it right I'm
having the donut because I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday or something right like
I'm getting the asparagus because I have
you know I want to live a keto lifestyle
or whatever it is right like explain the
thought process behind the decisions I
remember when I first got started on
social Twitter was was blowing up and I
thought Twitter was stupid like this
looks so stupid people are just sharing
pictures of their lunch and cats and I
have no interest in just sharing I'm I'm
a pretty uh private person believe it or
not like I have no need for you to know
what's happening in my life I have no
need to share it
but when I realized oh this is actually
thought leadership content that the
reason behind making this book or the
reason behind having these pictures on
my wall it's not about me showing off
it's about me trying to help other
people think the way I think so that
they can improve their lives as well so
everything you've got around you is a
story that hopefully has helped you
improve your life some way now bring
that back to bring not bring that back
into the audience so that they can learn
from you like why are you here why did
you pick up built to serve what was the
biggest lesson that you got from it all
of these could be individual stories
that again teaches people to think like
you think so Stephen wrote why is it
important to tell your story Okay so
and built the serve we talked about this
right
people need to connect to you
if they don't feel like you know what
they've gone through they won't listen
to you so
uh you know Evan has shared a lot about
his story with uh alcohol addiction and
you know you would look at Evan like
right now and you would say oh this guy
looks like he's polished and clean and
knows what he's doing and has his life
in order and you wouldn't necessarily
think that he was addicted to alcohol
and and I know Evan's okay with me kind
of sharing bits of his story here on the
Stream
so if somebody came and was struggling
with alcohol addiction and they came
across Evan and he said hey here's what
you have to do these three things
they say yeah that's great man but you
don't know what I've been through
you don't know what it's like you don't
you don't I mean I'm addicted you look
at you you've got your life together
it's all sorted out meanwhile Evan knows
exactly what it's like uh to contemplate
suicide to to be you know massively
addicted to have a lot of self-hatred
because of of the addiction of that
cause
and so unless people know what you've
been through they won't listen to your
advice like Evan has some of the best
advice to help people overcome it but
unless they know his story about how he
came through that they won't listen to
him
because people will naturally think well
you don't know what I'm going through
and so this is where you have to share
your story where you've came from even
the journey that you're still on right
we're still growing we're still learning
we're never done learning growing
getting better and improving but where
did you struggle where did you come from
because ultimately your purpose like we
talked about and built the serve is to
help other people who currently are who
you used to be
right there are many people who are Evan
from eight years ago
I've intense math we got two evidence in
the group I like using that as an
example right but there's also many
people who are having Carmichael from
eight years ago and that's who you're
talking to and that's who you'll love
helping the most you know Evan tinsman
will love helping anybody right and he's
been uh an amazing human in in the
movement makers group in this group even
when we first did our session in
Pittsburgh uh he was bringing value to
all the other people in the room he just
wants to help right he wants to
contribute which is fantastic
but helping somebody who
is currently struggling through alcohol
addiction is currently struggling with
self-worth is currently struggling with
uh potential you know suicide he'll love
helping those people more than holding
the door for somebody at a grocery store
or buying a Starbucks the person behind
him in line because that's who he used
to be and it's the same thing for all of
you and I'm telling I'm a story because
I know it better I don't know all of
your stories you know in detail but
you've all been through something
and those are the people who you're
going to love helping out the most it
just feels so much better it feels so
fulfilling that you represent hope to
them that when they see you
and what you've come through
it represents possibility for them
because they don't see possibility for a
lot of you where you are right now is
impossible
for where Evan is right now it's
impossible he shouldn't be here he
shouldn't be doing the stuff that he's
doing right now it's impossible Evan
from X number of years ago would look at
this guy and say there's no way you're
going to be doing that that's not
possible
but he did it yeah and so have you and
all of you are here right now and the
version of you five ten years ago would
say that's not possible and so that's
your job is to show other people who
currently are you from five or ten years
ago that it's possible that there is
hope that you can grow that you can
overcome that you can climb out of this
hole that you're in
but without sharing your story to the
question that Stephen asked without
sharing your story
uh nobody's gonna listen to you so
you've got all this great information
you've got the knowledge the tools the
the desire to help the willingness all
of it and you can help and you know that
it can help
but nobody's going to listen to you
because they feel like you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't been through what I've been
through right
so that's why it's super important to
share your story and and
um it's scary
it's scary to share your story it's
scary to put it out there it's scary for
people to know
um what you've been through you know
like using Evan again as an example he's
has a super successful uh practice uh in
insurance and it could be scary to let
that out to have clients have customers
have Partners have people in the
community know that you almost killed
yourself and you were addicted to
alcohol right like now you're not normal
anymore now you don't fit in maybe as
much anymore it could be scary for
people to know what you've been through
um
but if you are silent it perpetuates a
silence it means everybody else who's
struggling with it they stay silent too
and they become afraid to share and your
willingness to share to be brave to be
courageous to put your story out there
inspires other people to say hey I'm not
alone I'm not the only one going through
this and it's okay to share my story too
so I see that as your all of you your
responsibility to be able to do that so
okay Esmeralda is here how do I overcome
the fear of being in front of the camera
or sharing pictures of myself well
where's Esmeralda Esmeralda we could do
it right now it's called turning on your
camera
[Laughter]
hey we got lots of people hey there she
is Esmeralda
[Laughter]
it's one step look at all the high fives
and fist bumps and flexes you're getting
right I mean that's that's the start
uh so I do a couple of things one
is I tell myself that being afraid is
not a good enough reason
you don't want to teach yourself that
I'm afraid and I don't do it I'm afraid
and I play small I'm afraid to chase
down my dream and then I don't go for it
because that becomes this negative cycle
that we repeat and I love that you're
like in a in a grocery store or
convenience store somewhere there well
they're all still tuning in to the live
it's amazing uh but being afraid is not
a good enough reason if you can catch it
like the reason I want to do this but
I'm but I'm afraid that just mental
break down that wall being afraid is no
longer a good enough reason because
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of what you're afraid
of
every growth every opportunity every
breakthrough every client like
everything you want to do comes from
doing things that you're afraid of
otherwise if you're never afraid then
what then you
you stay stuck doing what you're doing
you just stay inside your comfort zone
it's just your life photocopying every
single day
are you at your job that's amazing I
think she's working there it's awesome
Esmeralda joining in
I remember when I had my one of the only
jobs I had was doing data entry at this
company and they wouldn't let me listen
to music so it was back when we had a CD
what's a CD man it's like the Walkman
but for CDs like a portable little CD
player so I used to have that on the
floor and then I ran a wire through my
jeans and I always wore a turtleneck and
I ran I got an extra long extension cord
for my headset for my headphones and I'd
run the wire under my turtleneck and
just pop out here to get one little
sound Bud to go into my ear so I can
listen to some uh mostly Andrea Bocelli
at the time while I was doing this super
boring data entry work so I love it I
love I love the hacks
um okay so to that question one is
fear alone is not a good enough reason
the second part is you're trying to
serve you're trying to serve you want to
help you're doing this you know you're
afraid to get in front of the camera but
why do you want to get in front of the
camera
take it from I want to it's not about
you being seen it's not about you being
this big famous name it's about you have
a message that can help people you're
here trying to serve and whenever I flip
it to it's about the audience it's about
the people who will see this is that
even if only five people see this video
maybe two out of those five people this
could actually be something
life-changing for them
it's not about you it's about them
that always gives me that extra little
bit of of confidence and push to go off
and do the thing that that I'm afraid to
do so I balance it between those two
things right I'll tell myself I'm Evan
christili Carmichael I do difficult
things or I do scary things or I do the
things I'm afraid of Plus
I'm here to serve and I'm here to help
and my message
can hopefully Touch Somebody Today it
may not but it's your intention going in
like the intention behind the action of
being in front of the camera is not to
screw people over it's not just to make
yourself famous it's to try to help is
to try to serve
and so I always take that mindset going
in before uh whenever I'm super nervous
uh or before never making any piece of
content it helps when you're when you're
even filming your own YouTube videos
because sometimes it's hard when you're
at home in an office maybe with Corona
you haven't seen any humans for the last
little bit and interact with them and
you just even here I'm talking just into
a camera and it's awesome to be able to
see your faces up here on the screen
to remind yourself that hey this is a
video that's not just me in my office by
myself you're making this video to try
to touch somebody else's life and when
you take that as an intention your video
will be better
when you just focused on oh am I looking
at the camera and is my mic set up and
all this other stuff your video won't be
as good compared to if you actually
picture somebody
in your head I used to do this all the
time because I had a hard time getting
into the zone and I was making content I
would picture somebody and I'm I'm
making this video for him this video is
just for him and I'm speaking to him and
and that would Channel him as I pressed
record on my camera and I'd always end
up getting a much better video man time
flies it's crazy we already got time
let's get to let's get to like super
rapid fire
uh uh how to deliver the idea message in
a simple way
uh oh hot chocolate readings I would I
would do a 30 second hot chocolate
reading every day and post it to
Instagram
hot chocolate reading of the day and
then whatever whatever the whatever
comes at every day right every day for
30 seconds
um from Denise what type of videos go
viral in your opinion if you know if I
had a recipe for making a viral video
every time
that'd be amazing like that's what
everybody's going after but really be
looking at
make the video that you from five years
ago badly needs right make the video
that the you from five or ten years ago
badly needs because the youth from five
or ten years ago probably wouldn't watch
an Evan Carmichael video
like ah that guy he's too energetic he's
too positive that can't be real I don't
know
you know like you don't want to listen
to those guys
but
you could you could touch you from five
or ten years ago in a way that Evan
Carmichael or Tony Robbins or Brendan
Bouchard or whoever else can't
and that's I think even much more
important than worrying about a viral
video that that blows up on the Internet
is having an impactful video that
changes somebody's life
so I'm still trying to make the content
that
uh that I need right now but also that
like five years ago Evan still needs uh
so that's always kind of in the back of
my head as well
I haven't since been saying disagree ooh
okay your content helped get this Evan
to where he is now well I love it thank
you everyone appreciate the love man
um love that five to ten years ago idea
brilliant yeah just to imagine you
from five or ten years ago or somebody
who is like you and you're making
content for that person because you know
again Jeff from five or ten years ago is
thinking a different way he's not
doesn't have as much of a growth mindset
is
not wanting to listen to a lot of the
messages that are being put up there you
know he would look at what you're doing
now so that's crazy you know with books
on the shelf and Bullseye and all these
goals and accomplish like you wouldn't
think that that would be possible uh and
so you can reach Jeff from five or ten
years ago in a way that nobody else can
what I'm looking to do is is try to get
some more insight on
um a new role that I'm going to be
playing at a startup so that's why I
thought maybe it might be helpful more
with yourself it's not to do with
blogging or anything it's part of an
accelerator program so a little bit of
that is is getting out of my comfort
level and and being exposed to startups
but further one to learn you know kind
of I've read the book and
kind of need a little bit more help in
terms of being able to structure my
career path I'd say and and understand
how I can be of service to these
institutions based on the experience
I've have with 20 plus years in real
estate and what I'm going into is real
estate technology startups cool that's
one question that's kind of come up to
my in my head so what are you doing at
the incubator
I'm assisting
um I'm actually co-running it oh cool
yeah it's with TMZ in our neighborhood
in Toronto oh you're in Toronto cool I
have uh out of uh Ryerson well I don't
even know what they call themselves now
but yeah Ryerson yeah it's not rarest
anymore yeah Metropolitan University or
University or something yeah and so is
that what you want to do you want to
like go co-found more I'd like to I'd
like to
um this is something new and you know
opportunities came about and something
I've been working on and it's taken
about two years to be able to find event
a VC to
um go back this and we're going to be
starting up uh in September I'm going to
be visiting the office later today
but that's something where I thought I
would be able to try to find out if I
can get some help from Zan or from you
just in terms of understanding again how
can I make an impact because a lot of
things you're seeing are are really
coming into into play here in terms of
being able to provide a service and
making sure that I have the opportunity
to grow and learn in that role
if that makes any sense
yeah most incubators don't work
yeah and most companies at incubators
don't work and so if you're looking for
like next stage in life and what to do
after like that if you make it work
you'll have unlimited opportunities
to to join other incubators to start new
incubators the key is like make this one
thing work right for the entrepreneurs
coming in they struggle with
um the biggest thing to struggle with is
closing sales like they struggle with
getting their product depending on what
stage what's usually is an incubators
it's early stage it's early stage yeah
so like yeah it's one getting getting
their MVP getting their mineral viable
product like created and then bringing
in Revenue that the business is shut
down because they can't generate
sustainable cash flow right so right you
know if you're in real estate you
understand the cash and sales yeah and
try to utilize the network is what
you're saying yeah so so helping them
get to the point where they're at least
covering their costs so that they can
hang around long enough to blow up like
so many entrepreneurs are focused on I'm
gonna go change the world with my new
tech startup cool yeah let's get to the
point where you can stay sustainable
right what's what are those first sales
that we need to bring in and whether
that's you making introductions to
people
it's a big reason why people would join
an incubator you know right you're going
to introduce them to somebody that's
going to help yeah or if you're gonna
just stay on them and train them like
helping them with their pitch helping
them with their decks helping them on
the phone helping them do the follow-ups
helping them become sales people a lot
of tech startups suck at sales because
they're yeah that's what I'm finding you
know but they did enough to get into
into the incubator so they sold
themselves enough to get in there so
there's they've got something but it's
that combination of of the training to
do better sales
um even the accountability like if you
if you uh help them stay entrepreneurs
suck with accountability
right yeah so like they say they're
gonna do something and they don't do it
see Evan
um or are you saying that's me I don't
know no no I'm writing this down now I
haven't had his hand up um but
entrepreneurs suck with accountability
especially at the beginning when they
have no idea then this is their first
thing so
helping them with that like coming in
and setting what's what's our sales plan
guys
what's our what
what's our sales plan yeah right and
then helping them actually create one
and stick to it and making sure that
they're doing the thing that they said
they were going to do not just going
into the tech that they love geeking out
over and you helping make introductions
for them
allows them to have success which then
allows the incubator to have success
which then allows you to go wherever you
want to go afterwards
got it yeah it's helpful I appreciate
that
yeah
um there's the whole motivation side so
they keep bringing guest speakers and
all that kind of stuff but really it's
like get the get them to a sustainable
business and then get them to to going
off and changing the world
and and sales playing in the
introductions so like for every business
identify their ideal clients and then
yeah your network and also friends of
friends who might be able to come in and
either buy from them or at least give
them honest feedback of of where they're
falling down like people will take a
meeting because they love supporting the
the university and they love supporting
the incubators right you take the
meeting if you reach out and it may not
become a client but at least you get
really good feedback
and they may not know how to do that so
if you spent you know
half an hour a week with everybody
trying to help them make those
introductions
some of those will hit and you'll end up
really having a lot of success there and
then that's it you just have to make
that one work
and then you could be the incubator Guru
and go around the world doing it like
most of them fail so you're a guy who
says in this one it's interesting
because I've got we're being backed up
by a large pension fund so that's going
to be a bit of a live case study in
terms of the companies or two or three
companies that we choose out of that
incubator to work on lean on them
okay lean on the investors and say hey
we've got a tech startup inside computer
peripherals or whatever we need we need
to get to these guys like every company
in their sales plan that comes through
you needs to make a list of their top 50
clients that they want to talk to and
you might know some of them already cool
and if not you lean on you talk to the
pension fund hey we need to talk to
whoever's in charge of tech at Royal
Bank
do you know anybody yeah okay got it
yeah I know where you come from is there
anything that you recommend I I read
any of your material or anything in
terms of because this is kind of really
pretty much what you are doing in terms
of helping the startups as well
um
I don't have a lot of good books direct
I don't really read a lot of books I
mean build to serve is great
good one required reading at the
incubator
um but honestly it's just
you just have to be a resource for them
like help them get sales
like if they're coming in they probably
already have a mission then they're
probably working on their Tech but like
how do they commercialize this and if
you have big uh like the pension fund
that's involved in in your thing cool
they're investing into tons of companies
like the amount they're investing in you
is so small compared to their entire
portfolio the problem is most people are
not most of their portfolios are not
reaching out asking for help
and they have a deep network of people
so you reach out and say hey we need to
get to whoever runs Tech at Royal Bank
to get feedback on this can you help us
yeah I hear you so you're saying
leverage dmz's resources to our
advantage and network yeah they're like
the resources as a network yeah exactly
The Tech Guys need to know the like the
com the startup companies need to know
how to create their thing
create the product or service but right
the network to get it into the hands so
it's commercializable that needs to be
pulling on DMZ pulling on all the
investors and that could be you to help
be the liaison for that
foreign
but most people aren't even asking yeah
yeah you're right no that's not the guy
who appreciate it yeah
cool thank you you got it
um
there you go
but you know what this is very meta this
is very meta like what Zen just did here
it you were acting like most of the
companies in your incubator act yep
you're right hidden camera off yeah not
asking questions but needing help or
like that's everybody who's coming
through your company
they don't want to turn the camera on
and ask for help and and talk about
their business because they'd rather
just stay tinker and attack and what Zen
said like hey come on and ask this
question
and hopefully you get no it I could have
not picked you I could have said no
screw this guy without his camera on I
could have like not given you good
advice but at least you took the shot
right yeah no I agree I need to beat the
Zen for everybody who comes in and help
open up even if like Zan didn't have the
answer to this question he would have
answered some other way but the way he
didn't have the answer but he
facilitated the connection that's all
you need to do you may not have the
answer to who runs Tech at Rural Bank
but you can facilitate the connection
for these people so they can start to
grow got it it's awesome thank you cool
thanks man there you go thank you Zan
that's what it's all about
Celine was asking what's the best way to
get one-on-one clients so honestly the
best way is through referrals as much as
I'm like a Content guy and I love making
videos and content but the best way is
through referrals like do a kick-ass job
with the people who you are doing work
with so that one they want to hire you
back depending on what you're selling
until they introduce you to other people
that like this person is so good that
they want to tell their friends about
you and and being most people won't give
or give a bad service like if somebody
asked you if you asked them how good was
my service they'll probably say oh yeah
yeah you did great but is it so good
that they want to then like you're
forcing them or guilting them to tell
their friends about you and a lot of
times that comes from
helping them Beyond just the thing that
you're helping them with like they're
coming to you for a reason cool but the
concept would be their chief goal
officer like what are they actually
trying to accomplish and go help them
accomplish that right so think about I
just came back from Vegas and I was
speaking an event and most speakers
pretty much every speaker flies in and
flies out and that's her thing right off
to the next thing my favorite thing is
to hang out in the hallway afterwards so
I speak on stage and then speak so much
in the hallway that Zane has to pull me
aside and say sorry guys last question
he has to go to bed
which is usually Nina's job but she
wasn't there so Zayn became my my Nina
uh for the for the for the for the trip
and and by the way zandina was very
grateful that you uh stepped in and and
uh helped with that because I I'll get
sick because I'll spend so much time
helping people in the hallway
um but if you think about like what's
the goal of
what am I being paid to do like to come
and speak cool but then I'm gonna stick
around in the hallway and help everybody
afterwards because that's helping the
client even so much more
right and then you get hired to come
back and then you get if they're
thinking about who are they going to
recommend to other people to speak
they're gonna they're gonna often pick
me because the extra work that you're
putting in so it's not that you're not
doing a good enough job it's like well
but they got a result cool but did you
help them so much that they feel like
almost guilted into trying other ways to
help you out
and so referrals is the number one way
to grow a one-on-one client business if
you're a service-based business the the
fastest way to grow it is through
referrals
now that doesn't necessarily scale
right that's not how you build a you
know 10 million dollar company
but it's the fastest way to get going
and get started if we're going to use
content so if you look at build to serve
we tend to always focus on the thought
leadership and the content but
there's three strategies at the back of
the book on how to win right there's the
fast passive Freedom there's
Partnerships and then there's thought
leadership and partnership is basically
what we just talked about it's like
referral strategies
uh for the content
that the best way to do it is to do the
thing that you're doing live on inside
your content so Zane wants a
self-confidence coaching he should be
doing confidence coaching as part of his
content calendar we had somebody in
brand Linux this morning uh who was
doing she helps actors
uh get get into Hollywood you know and
all the tips and so one of the video
ideas we came up with was her doing
critiques of people's audition reels so
to get into a film you have to do an
audition reel and send it in they never
get feedback on whether it was good or
bad they just know if they got the pot
or not so have them send the audition
reel to her
and she'll put a make a video on it
breaking it down and critiquing it and
saying all the points where where it's
falling apart like here's why you didn't
got hired I think we were going to call
it like why you didn't get the role or
something and she basically breaks down
and tells you why you didn't get hired
for the job what's wrong with it
if she wants to sell those services
it's much easier to get clients with
that kind of content than with here are
five ways to win in Hollywood
because the fact that you can speak
doesn't mean you're gonna be a great
coach
so what are you trying to sell and then
show me you doing it
right but the easiest way would be
referrals so I don't know what you're
selling
um Slimer we're trying to get clients
towards but go in even for free so Drew
and Jeremy are two people who I both
invested into and train the YouTube side
of things and they both have mid six
figure businesses now Jeremy would start
a little sooner Jeremy went from being a
stock boy at a grocery store making
minimum wage to then now having a mid
six figure business and he's like I
don't know if I want to work more than
35 hours a week it's like oh my gosh
subscribe
uh he's spoiled now Jeremy if you watch
me play you are spoiled
um
but how we started was it was a lot of
free calls because he wasn't very good
at the thing yet and so he did free
calls free YouTube breakdowns basically
pulling up somebody's Channel and do
breakdowns and that led to then some
people on the free calls would have
would call him back and say hey that was
really good how do I can I hire you
and that becomes the goal it's like you
ultimately want to be hired
but are you doing a good enough job on
the free today people to say wow I want
I want to hire this person to come back
so it's Outreach Zane had a great point
today in brandlytics where we were
pulling up somebody's Channel we didn't
know who they were it's just like use
them as an example he's like could you
reach out to them and tell them to fix
their thumbnails
and offer that as a service like yep
yep
like if that was my business or Drew's
business you could reach out and say hey
here's what's here's what's wrong with
your channel here's what I do I'd love
to help you fix it and some people might
just talk to you for half an hour and
take your ideas and run with it cool and
some people will say wow that's awesome
how can I hire you to do that because I
don't want to do that myself
and then those people hire you you then
you do a kick-ass job helping them and
then they find more ways to work with
you and refer you off to their friends
so that's the easiest way service-based
business to get your company off the
ground is referral based marketing by
doing a kick-ass job for them
the content is the scalable way to build
the business cool so let's uh let's turn
into some questions who's got something
how can I help put your hand up and uh
let's go through lady Lexi what do you
got so when you were talking earlier
about
um the whole response video I was
wondering because you do a lot of those
shorts where your team does on your
gaming channel
and I would really like to respond to
you get into it so I noticed that on
Tick Tock you can do some stuff like a
duet or stage but what do you do when
it's only on on YouTube so can I post a
part of your video like a picture in
picture but what what's the norm
you need to use something it's like
these is probably Zoom
where you screen share and then have you
on as well and just adjust the size of
you
like if I were to go screen share right
now you I mean we're doing Movie Makers
right I mean you see my PowerPoint
and then you see me still talking and
you can I can adjust the size of me to
be whatever
I make it small so you can see the
slides it's not like giant Evan covering
everything up but you can make it that
like ladies half the screen and whatever
you're reacting to is on the other half
that's probably the easiest way
and when it comes to title uh would I
say a response to you or would I create
a more catchy title
I would I would lead with a more catchy
title
and then
afterwards if it's not working you can
always look to split test it
okay so for example in in brand Linux
this morning we had a guy who was um
he's a copywriter for books for book
marketing
and he's already ranking at the top for
all of the like book copy marketing
keywords but nobody's searching for it
it's like it's a really small people
aren't looking book marketing copy so
he's ranking for all those but it's not
helping him drive his business forward
too much because nobody's searching for
those words
um so one of the things he does is he
does Amazon uh sales page copy so when
you write a book you need to have an
Amazon page and there's copy on the
Amazon page and we went together and
looked at the four hour work week
uh Amazon page and it sucked
it's got like two paragraphs there's
almost nothing on there so that could be
a good video for him of tearing apart
the for our work week page and saying
why it sucks and how to fix it
so the video if you look at a title in
that video it should be something about
the four-hour work week and how much it
sucks as opposed to my response to the
four hour work week sales page like
something that's going to catch
attention so people want to click on it
now it's ideally not just tearing it
down but then giving feedback right like
here's here's how to make it better
what you
watching and of course you got inspired
by descriptions on YouTube
yeah that's amazing
I don't think I've ever heard anybody
say that before ever I got inspired by
YouTube descriptions okay this is great
you know that you're like obsessing over
YouTube when you lead a question with I
got inspired by YouTube description oh
my God you're basically living inside
YouTube right now lady likes you okay I
love it I love it let's go what do you
got oh I'm I'm living in lumafusion
right now
it's a whole different ball game anyway
Sam calls from self-confidence coach
and I've been looking for a while how to
call myself today I was thinking about
um calling myself what was it called
again inclusion influencer because it
does have the the word inclusion in
there and I actually like to see myself
as an influencer it's way easier than
coach therapist trainer whatever
okay so you're asking what I think about
inclusion influencer yes it's okay I
don't know that I would I don't know
that I would lean on an influencer I
think it it's uh it still has a
22 year old up and coming vibe to it as
opposed to like if you're actually an
expert at it
so like inclusion expert I also saw
inclusion Creator passing by
yeah expert or Advocate or leader or
like just something with a little more
if it were me something with a little
more
uh gravitas to it if you know gravitas
uh what's uh
a little more stature to it
yeah
influencer I think people will
self-identify as influences and they
might look for I mean if you calling if
you're looking at uh inclusion
influencer it's something that nobody's
looking for like nobody's going to
YouTube or Google anywhere and typing I
need to find an inclusion influencer
right so so now it's a branding play
like what do we want to call ourselves
is this is not for not for somebody
searching so like if somebody's trying
to find a confidence coach then they can
find Zan and they you kind of get a
sense of what it is right like he's a
coach he's gonna teach me confidence
that's what I assume it is if I go talk
to him and he's trying to sell me dog
food or something like this there's
something wrong here so but what's it
what's uh
inclusion influencer like you're you're
it's not immediately understandable so
it's fine it doesn't have to be but if
you're going to then pick something
that's not immediately understandable
then let's pick something that
speaks to speaks to the you know
Prestige I guess that you're going after
so if you're going to call yourself an
inclusion leader or Advocate it just
comes off I think more powerfully than
influencer
if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love